sadly we start today with a tale of
stochastic terrorism perpetrated by the
twice indicted twice impeached failed
former president you know the guy I'm
talking about the guy who's orange Trump
posted Barack Obama's address or what he
believed to be Barack Obama's address or
what was supposedly Barack Obama's
address and even though it wasn't an
armed man showed up
and prosecutors now know all about it
the Associated Press reports Trump
posted what he said was Obama's address
an armed man was soon arrested there and
the question I have for you as we read
through this is did Trump know exactly
what he was doing
former president Donald Trump posted on
a social media platform what he claimed
was the home address of former president
Barack Obama
on the same day a man with guns in his
van was arrested near the property
Federal prosecutors said Wednesday
revealing you details about the case the
individual is a 37 year old Taylor
taranto who prosecutors say participated
in the January 6 riots on January 6 2021
he kept two firearms and hundreds of
rounds of ammunition inside a van he
drove across country
and had been living in according to the
justice department motion that seeks to
keep him behind bars on the day of his
June 29 arrest prosecutors said taranto
reposted a truth social post from Trump
containing What Trump claimed was Barack
Obama's home address in a post on
telegram taranto wrote quote we got
these losers surrounded see you in hell
podestas and Obamas that's a reference
to John podesta who chaired Hillary's
2016 campaign
taranto also told followers on his
YouTube live stream he was looking to
get a quote good angle on a shot good
angle on a shot
Federal Defender representing taranto
did not immediately return a phone
message seeking comment but emotions
seeking to have him released pending
trial
um the lawyer wrote that they're in a
motion the lawyer wrote taranto is not a
Flight Risk and he served in Iraq okay
um all right so does Trump know exactly
what he's doing when he does this sort
of thing I believe that the term
stochastic terrorism applies here
stochastic terrorism is a technical term
that is the epitome of what we are
seeing here when we say stochastic
terrorism what we mean is when public
figures or media Outlets sometimes it
will be Fox News or others they can
Inspire seemingly random acts of
violence by spreading hateful or
extremist messages to a large enough
audience that is likely to be receptive
to it and it is historically outside of
any legal liability
so I'll give you an example in fact we
we have real life examples this guy
Glenn Beck right wing nut I think he has
a show now on the blaze or one of these
right wing online things he used to be a
Fox News host he used to be a CNN host
okay for a while he would rant and Rave
about an organization called The Tides
foundation and he would say it's just a
horrible organization I don't even
remember at this point it's been so long
what it was that was so bad about the
tides Foundation but he would rant and
rant and rant he never directed any
particular person to go and do anything
to the tides Foundation but given that
the audience of Glenn macbeck was a
right-wing conspiratorially minded
audience receptive to having their
attention focused on whatever the
scapegoat of the day or of the week was
you could sort of predict in some
general sense that Glenn Beck's
Relentless focus on the tides Foundation
might Inspire an act of violence against
the tides Foundation you couldn't
predict
that you know Joe Shmoe III from Florida
would be the guy to do the act of
violence but you could say we know that
some percentage of the population is uh
um suggestible in this way and we know
that Glenn Beck's audience is big enough
where if it's even only point one
percent of his audience that would hear
him talk about the tides foundation and
go and do something that means there's
at least a handful of people who would
go and do it and eventually this story
ended less tragically than it could have
ended which was California Highway
Patrol I again the details elude me but
pulled over a guy with guns in his car
going to the tides Foundation because
Glenn Beck had talked about it that's
stochastic terrorism it's not that Glenn
Beck directed in the way that you might
say okay you're my accomplice for this
crime go and do this thing I'm legally
liable okay I tell you to do it give you
the means give you the reasoning or what
the inspiration it's not legal liability
so we use the term stochastic terrorism
that's what we're dealing here with
Trump putting out what he claimed was
Barack Obama's home address you know I
used to think that
Trump winning the 2016 election was one
of the biggest disasters in American
history
I don't know that I've given it enough
credit it's probably more like in modern
world history the election of trump and
the cult status of trump as a leader to
at least tens of millions of people
quite frankly probably one of the worst
events one of the biggest disasters in
modern world history and interestingly
enough Trump wants more people out
protesting for him fortunately it
doesn't seem that many people are
willing and that's what I want to talk
about next there's something really
disturbing we've been seeing in the news
lately the FBI is now Gathering huge
amounts of data on everything people do
on phones and computers and here is how
data Brokers collect information about
what you look at online where you go
your political views the FBI then buys
that data to keep track of you it is a
legal gray area that the government will
happily take advantage of they don't
need a court order they just do it but
it's not just the government because
criminals can end up accessing that data
and use it to Target you for phishing or
identity theft big tech companies
political campaigns can buy the data to
try to influence you but here is the
solution our sponsor incogni
automatically sends data removal
requests to the major data brokers who
are required by law to remove your
information upon request if any of your
information stays online incogni will
even follow up with them about removing
it and incognee keeps you updated with
details at every step so you know when
everything's been removed it is a
fantastic service that I use and my
audience gets sixty percent off go to
incogni.com Pacman use the code Pacman
the link is down below